It’s not the best time to
be a Russian sausage tycoon.
A Russian military general.
The editor of a Russian tabloid.
The head of a Russian ski resort.
A Russian rail magnate.
A Russian shipyard magnate.
Or Russian oil and gas executives.
On Christmas Eve, Pavel Antov reportedly fell
from the third-floor window of his hotel in India.
He had just celebrated his 65th birthday.
Besides his success in the
meat processing industry,
Antov was a member of a
regional Russian parliament.
He appeared to criticize a Russian missile
attack in a residential district in Kyiv.
A message from his WhatsApp account read:
"It's extremely difficult to call
all this anything but terror."
He later claimed that the message was
someone else’s - not his - and
reaffirmed his support of Putin.
So many Russian business executives
have mysteriously died that there’s
an entire Wikipedia page dedicated to them.
The number of dead reached 25 by the end of 2022.
Oil executive Aleksandr Subbotin
was allegedly poisoned with toad
venom in the home of a “shaman”.
To better understand what’s going on,
I spoke with an authority figure on Russia.
So I wanted to ask you if you believe that the
Kremlin is behind them all or if
the answer is more complicated?
It’s surprisingly enough more complicated. To
be honest, look, the Kremlin on the whole does
not need to kill people. The Kremlin has so many
other ways that it can threaten and intimidate,
and if need be, imprison.
Mark Galeotti is a professor at
University College London who recently
released his book: Putin’s Wars.
What we’re seeing is in part genuine cases
of accidents and suicides, particularly for
people who have suddenly lost their lifestyles
or business empires and so forth. But also,
a resurgence of something we saw in the 1990s,
which is in some ways murder as a business tactic.
Russia was in political and economic turmoil
following the collapse of
the Soviet Union in 1991.
Violence as a way of doing business was the norm.
What we did see was a lot of clashes,
rivalries over suddenly available
markets and so forth. And at that
time, absolutely, we saw a whole
spate of killings ranging from opportunistic,
someone being shot in a car park, all the way
through to some incredibly sophisticated ones
involving radioactive materials and the like.
Vladimir Putin was credited as the leader who
restored stability in the 2000s and 2010s.
However, following Russia’s invasion of
Ukraine and the crush of Western sanctions,
Galeotti believes the cutthroat
way of doing business is back.
All of a sudden, shall we say, the cake is
shrinking at quite a dramatic pace. And therefore,
this is what’s happening: we’re seeing
the resurgence of a lot of battle waves in
which actually, all of a sudden, people
are competing that much more fiercely
for controlling companies, controlling
resources, controls of markets.
I don’t think this is a kind of
sinister plot by the Kremlin.
Another Russian expert I spoke
with came to the same conclusion.
Peter Rutland is a professor of government
at Wesleyan University in Connecticut.
The sanctions that the West imposed on Russia;
the freezing of bank assets, the seizure of
some foreign assets, over 1,000 individuals
have been put on sanctions lists by Western
governments. So that’s made the lives of Russian
businesspeople very difficult, very stressful.
In a country with the third highest
suicide mortality rate in the world,
he says it's highly probable that some
of the tycoons took their own lives.
To be clear, the Kremlin
does kill when it wants to.
In 2006, Alexander Litvinenko, a former Russian
intelligence agent who defected, was poisoned with
a cup of tea containing the radioactive
compound polonium at a hotel in London.
Russia is the only country that produces polonium.
The conclusion that the Russian
state was probably involved in
the murder of Mr. Litvinenko is deeply disturbing,
Litvinenko’s story has now been
dramatized in a mini-series.
The man who says I must die, I know this person.
What is his name?
His name is Vladimir Putin.
There’s been a long history of
poisonings linked to the Kremlin.
Jailed opposition leader, Alexei Navalny
was nearly killed by a nerve agent in 2020.
Investigative journalist Anna Politkovskaya, a
vocal Putin critic, was poisoned on a flight but
survived. Two years later, she was shot and killed
in her apartment elevator on Putin’s birthday.
However, these political targets are unlike the
recent deaths involving corporate executives.
Businesspeople, frankly, you know,
if they want to get rid of them,
they can just arrest them. It’s a lot easier.
So, as easy as it may seem to
point the finger at the Kremlin,
the bigger picture is more complicated.
Nonetheless, the deaths are very suspicious.
Some even involve entire families.
Sergey Protosenya, the former deputy head
of Russia’s second-largest gas company, was
accused of killing his wife and daughter at their
Spanish villa with an axe, before hanging himself.
However, his former employer, Novatek,
said speculations about his death
“bear no relation to reality”.
This was backed up by Sergey’s son,
who was not in Spain at the time.
He told the UK’s Daily Mail: 'He loved my
mother and especially Maria my sister. She
was his princess. He could never
do anything to harm them. I don't
know what happened that night, but I
know that my dad did not hurt them.'
If the death toll continues in 2023,
speculation over their cause will remain strong.
As former Soviet Defence
Minister Georgy Zhukov once said:
“There are things in Russia
which are not as they seem.”
With the war in Ukraine, independent media outlets
have been shut down in Russia. Many have
tried to browse foreign media for news.
To help you browse quickly and
securely online, I recommend Guardio.
Guardio is an extension that protects
your information while you’re browsing.
It’s kind of like having an online
bodyguard that sits in your browser.
Guardio blocks 100X more harmful websites
and phishing attempts than its competitors.
Guardio will block dangerous downloads,
even if you’ve clicked download, to
ensure no harm goes to your computer.
You know those annoying pop-up ads? They may
indicate that you have malware on your device.
Guardio traces the sources and eliminates
the invasive notifications all at once.
You can install Guardio from the
Chrome or Edge store, as I did.
After installing, a free security scan will
detect existing threats found on your browser.
You can then get a FREE 7-day
trial to remove these threats,
enable real-time protection, and get real-time
alerts when your information could be at risk.
If you’d like to protect yourself and your
family from these emerging online threats,
you can start your FREE trial
by clicking my custom link in
the description: guard.io/newsthink
Guard.io/newsthink for a free trial,
and get 20% off your monthly subscription, which
is good for five family members at no extra cost.